hey this is Chris Jericho here and this
is Sera and you are watching snacked and
we're going to try some of our favorite
snacks oh okay these are PR cocktail
crisp which I don't know if you have in
Canada but these are delicious you threw
away the lead here yeah prawn cocktail
crisps AKA shrimp flavored chip yeah
that's right your favorite potato chips
yeah they're delicious all right they
actually don't taste like prawn at all
but it's still called prawn it kind of
takes me out of the game it's like if it
was called ass cocktail it didn't taste
like ass it still wouldn't want to eat
it this some dick chips wait can we C
something edit that out dirt it m
delicious
M it doesn't taste like a shrimp so you
it just tastes almost like kind of like
a barbecue chip that didn't get a lot of
of barbecue stuff poured on it we also
call it walkers in the UK not lays and
in case you're also wondering they're
made with 100% Great British potatoes
the good
stuff all
right so these are sour cream and onion
chips the reason why I chose sour cream
and onion is because when I was a kid uh
and came home from school mhm I would
always have a snack and it would be uh
sour cream and onion chips and the
problem is I would eat the whole bag you
taste like onion for like a week
it's terrible so if you want to eat
these chips make sure that your girl guy
whatever it is that you're into also eat
sour cream and onion chips that way you
can still kiss them how diabolical is it
too to say of all the flavors of chips
let's do sour cream and
onion it smell is still that in my mouth
it's just it's no good I just don't like
sour cream look at the look on your face
I know I don't I don't know like I mean
it's terrible I used to eat a whole bag
of these damn things I know you're a
psychopath Wonder have a girlfriend till
I was 21 once you stopped though the
ladies lining up I went from L to too
late oh yes okay bring them on oh yeah
baby this is also a childhood candy of
mine it's fudge fudge is a little
different in the UK than it is over in
America I feel like fudge is more like a
chocolatey thing over here it's not it's
more like a caramel fudgy consistency is
delicious it's got chocolate wrapped
around it dig in and also too by Cadbury
which is a huge Canadian company as well
so I think that's a a commonwealth
crossover oh man he's are good it's good
so I'm from norch England and it's a
small City but it's good for music I
actually saw she did yeah I saw fzy
before I got to WWE I saw him live cuz I
was such a big fan and here we are look
how far we've come eating fudge together
on International TV best of friends yes
and we didn't have much money grown up
and this candy was delicious but it was
also super cheap it has a Nostalgia
taste to it and a good memory cuz my my
parents still tried to spoil me a they
didn't have much money so yeah these
Lifesavers right here that's a good
story exactly uhoh holy okay so uh
these are Big Turks a Big Turk is a
candy bar critically panned in my high
school as the worst candy bar of all
time I'm glad you brought it here today
yes I wanted to bring this up the big
turke it's a Turkish delight which is
chocolate around some kind of gelatin
jelly type thing myob they had Turkish
Delight in England too but not these and
I hated Turkish delight so I'm excited
that you are surprising us once again I
haven't had one of these in a while yeah
all the people that like them are in
jail
all right
exactly I'm like shaking I know I'm like
it's just rubbery it's not good it' be
like if there was like an oyster inside
of chocolate how can you still be in
business yeah what is wrong with you
unless of course you're going to sue me
for saying that in which case hi I'm
Chris Jericho when I'm looking for
something tasty big Turco you can't even
get the words out I could I was g i
gagged on my on my promo he's straight
up gagging I really did Chris you put
this on your list if you're favorite
snacks I'm wondering why why he's doing
a rib I wanted to kind of be the devil's
advocate here like every snack can't be
great sometimes a bad one slips through
the cracks and this is one of them if
you like a Big Turk you're a big
jerk
yes oh yeah so it's my turn and these
are digestive biscuits and in England we
like to dip biscuits and tea and this
was my go-to and they come with caramel
or orange or anything on them these just
plain MH but sometimes you crush them up
and put them on the bottom of cakes and
cheesecake and stuff it is delicious I
would eat a whole pack of these to
myself digestives are also very big in
Canada something that if you went to
your grandma's house she would have a
plate of digestives you can eat I could
eat the out of a digestive
delicious I can eat like 20 of them oh
it's broken they do crack easily though
oh good it really doesn't even taste
like anything it tastes like kind of
like a vanilla wafer my favorite thing
though the name digestives yeah it's
kind of off footing it's not the most
appetizing of it sounds like you're
going to your back that's what I'm
saying you're going to digest
them
[Music]
Pocky so Pocky is a treat that you find
in Japan they've now broughten over to
the States but when I first started
going to Japan the two things I always
used to eat with Pocky and pukari sweat
and pukari sweat is an energy drink and
once again not a very appetizing name
it's parari sweat well the reason for
that is because you're sweating and you
need to be replenished so have a parari
sweat so I would have a fine parari
sweat along with some pocket you know
Pocky comes in a multitude of different
flavors there's strawberry Pocky there's
green tea Pocky there's like birthday
icing Pocky and it's basically like um
like a biscuit dipped in chocolate for
example
yeah M it's like mini bread sticks I
love it yeah it's very small you know
you can eat like 50 of these and not
really peel anything yeah yeah I mean
I've spent a lot of time in Japan and
the UK you have as well and there's so
many different wrestling Styles that's
different depending what country you're
in around the world like UK was always
seem to be a little bit more technical
whereas like Mexico is very cartoon
based because they're wearing the
Luchador masks they're kind of like real
life superheroes and then Japan is much
more fighting Spirit Strong Style beat
the out of each other they beat the
sh of each other and I find like
American wrestling somewhere in the
middle of Mexico and
[Music]
Japan that was amazing kind of a walk
down snack Memory Lane this is uh CHR
Jericho and I'm serea and she's the aw
Women's Champion yes I am baby and you
can see her every Wednesday on Dynamite
every Friday on rampage and every
Saturday on collision sometimes I'm on
but I'm usually just carrying her
[Music]
bags